some people think the covet 19 vaccine  is making them magnetized  now let's get this straight vaccinations  could never do this but what if your  body was actually magnetized  well there are some people who've  reportedly have this ability they're  able to stick metal and other objects to  their skin but upon further inspection  it's been discovered that these people  just have unusually sticky skin now if  your skin really was magnetized it  wouldn't be good you encounter metals  every single day they're in your phone  computer your car  basically every electronic device  all these metals would start to stick to  you you wouldn't be able to use them and  your body would get weighed down by all  the metal and also depending on how  strong your magnetic field is you could  damage whatever you're touching ruining  it for good so sure something like this  could be a fun party trick but  ultimately it would be terrible for your  body did you know